going on everybody welcome to another
Raspberry Pi tutorial video in this
video we're going to be talking about
how to stream video from your Raspberry
Pi camera module to another computer so
if you try to look this up a lot of
times you're going to find something on
motion and what motion is is it's a kind
of a security program that works on
motion detection and so you could you
know you would use it as like a security
camera for our purposes and for I think
what a lot of people might want to
stream video for it's not for it
necessarily a motion detection system
for security they're just trying to
stream video so that's what we're going
to be talking about here so the first
thing we want to do is we're on our
desktop here and we're going to want to
open up the terminal now in the terminal
but what we're going to want to do first
is run sudo rasp I - config if you
haven't done this to enable your camera
yet basically is what we're doing so if
you just now plugged in your camera
you'll need to enable the camera and all
that but I've already enabled mine so I
don't need to the next thing you're
going to want to do is we're going to
want to run sudo apt-get install VLC and
what this is going to do is it's going
to install VLC media player and all the
things with it onto our BIOS berry pie
now anyone who's familiar with VLC media
player it's just a phenomenal free
software you can do all kinds of things
with it watch and listen to just about
any sort of file type you can convert
files these are all kinds of stuff in
VLC it's crazy and I found out that you
can also stream video with with VLC so
there's just a million things that this
program does so we're going to use VLC
we're going to stream the data to VLC
here and then we're going to use the
HTTP protocol to stream it to our
Windows PC so you will also need to
install VLC media player on here I guess
you could have it on Windows Linux
whatever you need to put VLC media
player on another whatever computer
you're trying to stream to so I've
already installed VLC so I didn't have
to do it but after you do this allows
you yes you want to install yeah you'll
hit yes so now you've got VLC now make
sure you have VLC on your other
computer as well and the next thing that
we want to do is we run the following
here so I'm just going to copy and paste
it I'll put a link in the description of
exactly what you need to do it's a very
long input for all the commands and
stuff but I'll explain what's happening
oh my goodness I can't taste it let me
open I'm not typing this app come over
here and we have VLC so let me go ahead
now okay so what this is going to do is
it's going to record via a spy vid so
that's what the camera module and it's
going to start immediately it's going to
horizontally flip the stuff that way
it's we're not getting like this weird
mirror effect going on the width height
frames per second all that basically
what all this other stuff means is on
port 80 160 we're going to be
transferring this data using HTTP and
the file type h.264 okay so basically is
just going to ask you out this stuff so
let's go ahead and hit enter and that'll
start streaming hopefully now you might
see a lot of weird things like this um
this is for cable so now what you'll
want to do is open up VLC on another
computer so I'm actually on my desktop
so I'm going to open that up and let me
make it a proper size I suppose okay so
here's VLC you want to go to media open
a network stream and then here is where
you're going to access HTTP colon slash
slash the IP address of your Raspberry
Pi if you don't know it do ifconfig and
then colon port 80 160 since that's what
we specify and then hit play and what we
get is the stream where is my out
staring at a box but now we can do some
really wild stuff okay
so now we're looking at the computer but
apparently it's not good enough
anyway okay so that is the camera module
for us and we are streaming data from it
my room is a massive mess actually
I am in the process of moving probably
one of the last videos I film here but
anyways that's it that's all you have to
do now it's streaming video it's not
laughs I don't if you use motion JPEG
but it's pretty poor quality in the
frames per second if you try to give it
anything realistic at all in the frames
per second
it lags out pretty bad so that just
wasn't doing it for me whereas this is
actually quite good and I do have that
I've got a video of me streaming from my
card on my PC the Raspberry Pi car that
we made so anyways that's it if you guys
have any questions or comments feel free
to leave them below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and it's the next time